yo what's up this is ice cube and you
know what I'm doing I'm doing the Google
audio complete interview hi
let's see what is ice cubes best song my
best song is it was a good day because
it's my biggest song it's a song that if
I don't do it'll be a ride in the stands
so I got to perform it was a good day
every day of my life that I'm performing
what is Ice Cube real name my real name
is O'Shea Jackson but since I got a
junior and he's famous
I got to call myself O'Shea Jackson
senior which sucks
what is Ice Cube's workout routine going
from the kitchen table back to the couch
and then back to the refrigerator and
then back to the kitchen table and then
over to the couch again my workout
routine what is Ice Cube's favorite
movie my favorite movie is Charles I
love Charles because it is to me the
perfect movie adventure
popcorn scary cool is everything all
that wrapped into one
all right what else we got it's ice cube
a nice guy in real life yeah sometime
they call me nice cute it depends if you
owe me money if you owe me money not
that nice all right
it's ice cube in a video game yep
I'm in Call of Duty I play the guy who
gets killed a too soon in video game
it's ice cubes - what am I still alive
no it's ice cube a good dancer nice up
you know I actually only do one dance
which is called gangsta two-step and it
only got two steps and I still need help
with that is Ice Cube related to ice tea
ah no
he's the homie we both got the first
same first names but my surname is cube
his his t we don't have the same daddy
sorry y'all alright
where did Ice Cube get his style from
umm I got my style from my neighborhood
ain't got my Chuck Taylors on but they
usually Rock Chuck Taylors five on one's
khakis t-shirt size cetera et cetera no
I mean I keep it simple but I don't keep
it stupid where do I go to college well
I didn't go to college I actually went
to a dumbass trade school called Phoenix
Institute of Technology
I took architectural drafting and I got
my certificate I threw it in my closet
cuz I ended up rapping and doing the
I'm doing right now and the reason
I'm doing this interview so no college
should have went but I didn't where did
Ice Cube get his name from I got my name
from my brother
my brother he's about nine years older
than me so he used to have all kind of
women calling the house I would try to
get at him he got mad at that he said he
was gonna slam in the freezer one day
turned me into an ice cube so I was like
you know what that's a badge of honor
when I walked out the house that day I
told him don't call me on shade no more
you know I found my nickname is gonna be
cubed it's gonna be Ice Cube so from
then I start calling myself ask you
where did Ice Cube learn how to rap
actually learn how to rap watching other
rappers but my friend and who was a
producer my name sir jinx he actually
helped me start rapping where I was
right on beat he brought me in there and
he was like no you gotta hit it on this
got it you got to be on this rhythm this
that now this so thank you jinx what
else I got does ice cube have any
tattoos nope I don't have no tattoos
having figured out what I want to write
on myself permanently so there's Ice
Cube still tour yes I do
all the time got a lot of festival dates
to do this year doing Coachella the
biggest music festival in the world yep
I'm still torn and when I
come to your town I'm gonna see you at
my show there's ice cube drink alcohol
hell yeah you got something that's what
you're talking about you know I don't
drink that cheap cuz Ice Cube talk
to Dre talk to Dre yesterday no we
talked about we talked about the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame
Dre you're gonna rock oral Hall of Fame
I don't know I wasn't gonna go but out
yeah I think I'm going so Dre will be
there we will be there and I think we
talked about Coachella - all right let
it
Google auto-complete interview
it's a rap